Good morning, everyone.
That was awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
No pressure.
Anyway.
My name is Sergio Cantu.
I'm a second-year physics
PhD student, here at MIT.
I would like to thank
you for having me here.
So, let's start!
This year's theme for the MLK
celebration is student power.
And to be honest, being selected
for the graduate address
was a very big surprise to me.
Mostly because up
until last year at MIT
I went from feeling totally
powerless to realizing
that I have a lot more
power than I realize.
But the thing I'm
proudest is that I learned
how to help empower others.
And I hope that by
the end of our chat,
you will also
learn that you have
more power than you realized.
But, let's go back
to the beginning.
When news first got out
in my undergraduate school
about me going to
MIT, it was-- I
was going to as
part of the Bridge
to PhD program-- faculty
and graduate students alike
kept telling me how
much I will learn
and how I would grow
both academically and
professionally.
It felt like
winning the lottery.
After a local news story, people
will approach me on the street
and congratulate me
for making it out.
And to please go
back and save them.
You see, I knew the
sentiment too well.
You would, too, if you were
born in the city of Brownsville,
Texas.
A small city in Texas on
the border by the sea.
More than 35% of
residents in Brownsville
live under the poverty line.
The highest poverty
rate nationwide,
according to the 2014 US census.
And it was also the least
educated city in 2015,
with the lowest percentage
of high school diplomas
and high school degrees.
While this celebration
was going back at home
of me coming to
MIT, I didn't want
to be defined-- you know, to
have my defining characteristic
at MIT-- to be my background.
I was afraid that
my upbringing would
be used against me if
I didn't know something
in lab or in class.
To my surprise, MIT has
felt like a family to me,
made of people from all
levels of the institution.
Some people like-- I need to
stop and say some people--
Ed Bertschinger who
opened the world to me,
and Monica [? Huerta ?]
that I think
is somewhere here,
and a lot more
people that I
couldn't list today.
ACME, of course.
Later, you know, when I was
admitted into the PhD program,
I didn't hesitate in
saying yes to MIT.
And I can only hope that I
can say the same type of yes
when I get married.
But even with all
the support, it
didn't prepare me to last year
when my worst fears came true.
You see, Texas shares a border
with the state of Tamaulipas
on the Mexican side, one
of the most violent states
the drug related violence.
My family has experienced
this violence firsthand
while I have been here at MIT.
And like many others,
they have been
forced to leave everything
behind and moved to the US
with the hope that
they can be safe.
While growing up in Mexico,
this felt very normal.
It was like business like usual.
But now at MIT, I was
able to feel and see
the with a different lens.
And they gave me a
little bit of objectivism
to the whole situation.
And it left me feeling
powerless, completely
powerless.
Because I felt like I was
so powerless and scared
that if something were
to happen to them,
I would have to leave everything
that I was doing at MIT to go
back to my family and
pick up the estate,
you know if anything
happened to them.
I must confess I followed
the textbook example
at MIT of what not to do.
I kept it to myself.
I allowed myself to wear a mask
around MIT, and even at home,
while my family kept
traveling to Mexico.
It was impossibly difficult
for me to share it,
even with my own MIT family.
And I started isolating
myself even at work.
It was difficult because
I felt like by opening up,
I would just perpetuate
a stereotype of violence
in Mexico.
But I couldn't stay quiet and
let people like Donald Trump
characterize Mexicans
and Mexican Americans
as rapists and criminals--
[APPLAUSE]
Unbeknownst to me,
across the country people
were engaging in a
similar conversation.
A Facebook poll in 2015
showed that the two
top political issues were both
racial issues and immigration.
So I decided to be more active.
I decided to do my part
and bring the conversation
to campus.
And get to know the
students around me.
During in my
conversations, I noticed
that even though MIT has
come a long way in terms
of gender and
diversity inclusion,
there is still a long way to go.
Domestic underrepresented
minorities at MIT
constitute 14% of the total
graduate student population.
However, most
underrepresented minorities
pursue master's degrees.
And being a PhD student, I
have certainly noticed that.
Getting to know people
around me allowed
me to connect to other
Mexicans and Mexican Americans,
both undergrad and grad at
MIT, Harvard and other places.
And I found them extremely
passionate about science,
and just like me, they share my
concern for Mexico's problems
as well as diversity
in academic circles.
I also learned that some of
the grad students have started
an effort called "Clubes de
Ciencia"-- or "Science Clubs"
in English-- to
confront these issues.
And I joined them
in a heartbeat.
Although we were very
excited about this,
our priorities
still were our lab--
we're grad students
at the end of the day.
So we needed to be
efficient about this.
So how do I do it?
Well, I basically-- we basically
approached it the same way
we approach any problem in lab.
If you want to fix
something in your lab,
you want to
characterize it first.
And for that you need to know
three facts about drug cartels.
Number one is the
drug cartels in Mexico
employ close to half a million
people across the country,
making it the fifth largest
employment industry in Mexico.
Number two is that the average
drug cartel members 18 years,
didn't finish middle school,
and lives in extreme poverty.
And number three is that
Mexico loves entrepreneurship.
Mexico has the largest number
of self-employed citizens
in the world, it's 25%
for men and 17% for women.
So it comes as no
surprise that when
you interview the criminals
that got convicted
to drug-related crimes
75% will tell you
that they have a high interest
in starting their own business.
Which lets you know that
if there's something
that they hate more than
the law, it's their boss.
[LAUGHTER]
And MIT knows a thing or
two about entrepreneurship.
We have seen MIT grads companies
such as Intel, Dropbox,
and my personal favorite,
video game company
Harmonics-- creators
of Guitar Hero.
How does MIT do this?
By providing the skills,
mentorship, and resources
necessary for students
to achieve their goals.
So that meant that our
goal was very clear.
To empower high school
students in Mexico
before they stray away
into a life of crime.
We do it by bringing in
scientists and engineers
from all over the
world to Mexico
in the form of
one-week workshops.
It is in these workshops where
students empower themselves
with knowledge while they
build their own lasers,
photograph the curvature of the
earth with aerostat balloons
that they build themselves, and
learn about neuroscience with
worms that they grow
themselves-- that's not that--
[LAUGHTER]
Despite that, they
experience and build
things that they only imagine
really opens their world.
For example, we had a
grad student from Caltech.
He had a very successful
biophysics workshop.
And his name is Manuel Razo.
However, what students remember
the most about this experience
was not the techniques,
it was not the concepts
that they learn from him.
But the fact that he learned
exactly those same techniques
and concepts when he
was in our first Club de
Ciencia two years ago.
The students loved it.
And so far we have had
the benefit and privilege
that we have reached more
than 1,000 students so far,
in nine different cities, in
three different countries.
In closing, I want
to remind everyone
that have a lot more
power than you realize.
And that only together we can
fix the problems of today.
But you have to do something.
You have to volunteer.
You have to sign up.
You have to cooperate.
In the words of Martin Luther
King, "If you can't fly,
then run.
If you can't run, then walk.
If you can't walk, then crawl.
But whatever you do,
keep moving forward."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]